it's time to babble the [ __ ] ah
live from the Jon Lovitz podcast theater
kids with your hosts Kevin Smith and
Ralph Garman
[Music]
man it is Saturday night in Halle [ __ ]
so let's babble to [ __ ] on I'm Kevin
[ __ ] and I'm Ralph [ __ ] hey get it right
out of the way get all that personnel
away
thanks for being here tonight folks you
sold this out [ __ ] give a hand yeah
thank you so much
another sold-out show thank y'all we
seen Lovitz in awhile haven't seen him
as he ran a wasp in a while
hope he hasn't sold out to Dana Carvey
or somebody okay oh the club yeah he's
sold out I'm a little off-center tonight
dude I'll be honest what are you smoking
this this week the strain of the evening
is kenobi OG in OB OG in your hearts
this evening my kid right before the
show my wife's like you got to bring the
kid with you I can't bring the kid to
the [ __ ] show they drink there and
[ __ ] and I'm gonna say a lot of weird
things yeah and she goes no not to the
show she just wants to go up to City
Walk I was like to do what she's like
hang out with her girlfriend I was like
well I can't I'm gonna be doing the show
and she's like they don't need you
there's gonna walk around I was like
these two kids just gonna walk around
[ __ ] City walking [ __ ] get a hit on
by [ __ ] 14 15 year old boys yeah so
[ __ ] I reserve the right at a
moment's notice to like leave here and
go kick some [ __ ] teenagers ass well
for the sake of the show just drag the
kid in here and beat the kids ass up
here they do the entertainment value
don't wanna [ __ ] seem like a bully or
something do it in front of people I
just want to do it quietly you know an
aside all about your pretty bold now
that you beat up an owl you're pretty
oh you throw [ __ ] an owl at me a
child oh yeah the mics going dude
thank you yeah mics are sort of
important for this show
or else what would Kevin pretend to
fellate if we didn't have a microphone
but to be fair so far nothing we've done
is really warrant of the mic it's been a
slow start man hurry up with that new
mic dude things are hold on here we go
and let's all watch okay holding Kurt
handing off a mic kind of thing it's not
excuse me I like to do a couple songs
while we're changing the microphone all
right man we're [ __ ] backs are any
event my kid out there getting overruled
by other [ __ ] dudes cuz I remember
what I was like when I would go out on a
Friday night it was like let's look at
breasts you know and I didn't say
breasts Ralph so I'm a little on edge
did you just look down
I tell you I'm a little on edge II
immediately go for the boob joke
that's my only [ __ ] joke sorry I
didn't know what I was thinking all
right let's start the show as we do
every week by talking to some folks who
came particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions here at
the Jon Lovitz with Hollywood babble-on
we call this segment the shout outs its
shout out Kevin Brown so get your [ __ ]
out
[Music]
yeah can we change the mic out it works
perfectly first and foremost we're Mike
a rock people there they are right down
front hi guys we got a large group here
from the radio station kroq-fm here in
Los Angeles on was that about it's it's
our sales our sales gang came out to you
to represent and to support us here at
the show these are the people right here
these are people who will [ __ ] me out
on a daily basis and I appreciate that I
think it was them going like he says
he's got this weekend job we don't
believe it yeah they were sent by
management to make sure it wasn't
selling drugs or something which I will
be at welcome welcome yeah there will be
drugs as parolees also here coming from
a particularly long distance or in
Freedman or in you in the house all the
way up there on the third floor or in
Wright's huge fire show will be here
from Chile New York City is that a like
a borough I think he means it's
particularly cold in New York City these
days Oh like chilly a New York City
little China Japan little chilly I'll be
here with my Rebecca with my Rebecca
with my girlfriend Rebecca who has
graciously agreed to attend the show
with me showing no hard feelings for my
repeated attempts to force Hollywood
babble-on
on her great trick for this turn on the
child locks before she gets in the car I
think even she's starting to like it
anyway I figure the only surefire way to
get her to give up the rusty wagon wheel
his first easing her into the oral orgy
that is Hollywood babble-on I can I just
tell this woman [ __ ] run from this
guy man
this letter is [ __ ] creepy all the
hell man he's like I want to lock the
car doors and [ __ ] do oral and the
rusty wagon wheel
now our role as in listening our role he
wants to stick it in her [ __ ] ear
hello
run lady Orin writes I truly appreciate
it if charlton heston could ask could
ask Rebecca to share her funky Applejack
with me tonight I'm not familiar with
the funky Applejack sir
and why funky wouldn't it be like brown
cinnamon apple Jeff we don't know
Rebecca we don't know what her hygiene
habits are maybe it's a funky Applejack
no no so you want the charlton heston
legendary star of screen to convince
your girlfriend Rebecca who's already
reticent to a share her sphincter with
you sir is that what you're asking for
now romantic okay Rebecca your
boyfriend's a deviant he can get your
funky Applejack
when he pries it from your cold dead
hands
there you go testing for you it's a
madhouse
the doors are locked frightening date
frightening thing Doug Poole from Rancho
Cucamonga California are you [ __ ] out of
here is that real I thought that was
like a [ __ ] Bugs Bunny address that's
a real place really bad show got my guy
I remember somebody said that in one of
the cartoons looking real that's where I
want to live man that says like a
happiest place on earth on that counter
place we you go to Rancho Cucamonga and
your driver Zamboni funny town man my
name is Doug a huge fan of both you guys
were here at the lovest this week with
my brother Kurt for his birthday Kurt
could you please give a birthday
shout-out to my bro and the voice of the
greatest public speaker ever Harrison
Ford I would greatly appreciate it at
Doug cool there you go that's enough
Aaron Kirkpatrick
[Music]
rollercoasters an Irish girl phone
ballistics it's the first episode rights
Aaron so pleased to be able to come all
the way from Maine for my very first
live show a man the entire state's
population is here tonight Apple of a
represented that's raising pick it some
sort of quorum second celebrating my
28th birthday that's the sexiest
birthday isn't it she writes why the
[ __ ] is that the Hat the sexiest
birthday understand she just said look
at me she just did one of these gang
signs man got in from Maine she's like I
picked a side I'm here of my friends
John and Judy who are graciously hosting
me and showing me la over the weekend
I'm not certain they've ever heard the
podcast well that's great so it would
not only be the best birthday gift ever
but also super appreciated if you would
have Bain explained to them what to
expect on this madcap show Aaron adds
please don't leave out the anal that's
important I think we've amply covered
the anal tonight Aaron
so mr. Bain Aaron would like it if you
could welcome her friends John and Judy
to the Hollywood babble-on show Judy
let's not stand on ceremony here mr.
mrs. main
[Music]
thank you and because he does the
impression uh here at Babylon we
advocate copious amounts of banal and
then we wonder which will break first
your spirits or bubble welcome to our
table saloons protected your bow is all
that the anal sex painful mr. Baine is
that painful it's extremely painful
will you yeah
Aaron new earth Aaron Aaron's here with
his buddy Ken my name is Aaron I'm from
down in Orange County California
attending the show with a few friends of
mine and wonder if I get a shout out for
my friend Ken who'll be at the show ken
has been a great friend of mine since
college and he's been living down in
Orange County near me but soon will be
moving up to Northern California meaning
we won't be able to hang out nearly as
often so his hoping you could spend a
cent a special shout out his way instead
of a device from The Sound of Music
I was hoping Ralph you possibly sing so
long farewell from The Sound of Music in
the voice of Sean Connery that would
mean a whole lot to canned if Ralph
could pull this off it mean a whole lot
to Ralph if Ralph could pull this up
this is [ __ ] pretty tender man it's
like Brokeback Mountain why does every
male friendship have to put you in mind
of guys spitting on their hands intense
that's the only reason guys whatever
always in the movie what do you want me
for
I remember that scene you think I can't
quit you
it wasn't that intense but you know Sean
Connery's saying goodbye to Ken okay so
wrong
farewell it's the tender moment here
okay it's just what a good job it is man
my job is in here and listen you figure
out how to [ __ ] sing this song has
someone else if you did it wrong
would you stop it we're just watching
the impression from one side this is
what it looks like he's like oh okay so
long farewell auf wiedersehen good luck
I'd like to say that I don't give a [ __ ]
it's not gonna get any better than that
Lord Tricia and Haim are you guys here
tonight where are you words now I'll
make some words up cuz do you know the
rest of the word I know the first line
yes you do it as Sean Connery look I am
look I am to life and if our good
fortune never comes here's to whatever
comes to life oh I forgot to let that
[Music]
[ __ ] Fiddler's in the roof now that's
what we're reduced to we're ready for
dinner theater my name is Trisha I'm
here celebrating my 30th birthday with
my boyfriend and exquisite lover Haim
holy [ __ ]
man listen to me time you've got one
hell of a publicist I wish my lady would
write letters like that I'm married to a
fat man but he's a hell of a lover
exquisite exquisite exquisite yeah
really what does that mean exactly where
are you crime where are you what is he
what do you do oh you are attracted what
does that mean exquisite just does weird
[ __ ] with his mouth I thought your
Eskimo Pie meant he was I thought you're
asking what I meant
Oh what makes you an exquisite lover
hime we'll make some exquisite he's good
at what he does well so are [ __ ]
garbage nights when you choose a word
like exquisite you got to back it up man
that's that's a once-in-a-lifetime work
what makes it exquisite or all right
there you know I'll take that answer
oral survey says no one there it is
maybe it's the Hebrew national he's
packing you know it's all beaten the
answers to a higher power you know what
I'm saying
Haim bought me these tickets a couple
weeks ago knowing I'm a Abid fan even
though he had barely heard an episode oh
that's very sweet that's why he's
exquisite because he's thoughtful tender
smart smart he's like she seems to like
this if I give her this she'll suck my
dick probably not the way he put it we
have traveled from a long distance away
from a town known as San Diego through
treacherous lands to North Hollywood to
see you tonight we braved the horrors of
LA traffic and crazed celebrities to
fulfill my wish of making my 30th
birthday epic please ask Huell Howser to
tell him he's absolutely amazing for a
Jewish boy absolutely amazing for a
Jewish boy you racist [ __ ]
for a Jew he's okay basically and thank
you for making my 30th birthday special
Trish yes that's amazing
a Jew is banging a Gentile that's
amazing best thing about Jews snip snip
snip they are they're circumcised I've
seen them they're amazing
well good luck time it's hard to say
that where I'm from I'm no Jews in
Tennessee
they're amazing thanks for coming out
tonight guys what Richard and Jill
Kerrigan Jill you here yeah I'm here
Jill's here with her fiancé Tim she says
I'm here with my fiancé Tim as an
engagement present for my little baby
cousin Kyle who's introducing me to his
new girlfriend Natalie he gets how many
[ __ ] names are involved in this story
man Jill says he gets very upset when I
bring up how yeah how he's younger than
me it's only like eight weeks but it
totally counts well Tim is white don't
let this confuse you I wasn't confused
until you said that
because his family's from South Africa
oh [ __ ] diplomatic immunity finally
finally
could we get David Bowie to sing us to
congratulate Tim and I for getting
engaged that would be wonderful thanks
Jill no sadly I don't do that bit
anymore sorry
I'm kidding James happy congratulations
to Jill and Tim you're getting married
on the run [ __ ] for the rest of your
life boats him I'm sorry for you
congratulations June congratulations to
you happy marriage and wedding to you
I'm so happy you're getting married it's
not too late for you Tim you could break
the whole thing off now all right okay
that's quite enough for that thank I get
a little busy doing that yeah me too
you threw your leg over mine that was a
new move tonight then paid for it too
yeah we also get emails from all around
the world when today
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions you got a
plane to catch tonight James can't wait
for the introductions anymore this first
email is from Orlando Florida Bob
Everland is his name he writes I'd Drive
my daughter every morning to her
grandparents house because they watch
her during the day on Mondays I listen
to Hollywood babble-on while we drive
she is 18 months old good parenting Bob
figures he's in [ __ ] Florida - it's
my 18 year old daughter maybe absorbing
more than I realized this was all I
heard in the backseat during one of your
impressions I'm glad she hasn't picked
up the great ass part of the impression
yet I hope you enjoy here's a little
video Bob sent of his 18 month old
daughter in the backseat of his car
here's a little video from Bob say there
you go she's picking up on all the
oppression yeah she's gonna be on the
pole when she's 18 Bob ah speaking of Al
Pacino I guess it was what was it last
week you can't you pitched the idea to
the movie possessed my Pacino that's the
soul of Al Pacino possesses somebody and
then Al Pacino hems it's the soul of Al
Pacino's performance right heat right so
it's larger-than-life it's taken on life
of its own it possesses somebody and
then they have to get Al Pacino to get
the soul of Al Pacino's performance out
of the possessed so he's his own Pacino
ISM out of the victim yes and you
suggested that he drive a frozen icicle
of holy water through the chest of the
possessed person yeah that was how he
kills that's a horrible idea
anyway Nathan Gonzales wrote in and he
took it to heart this idea for this
movie you had so he did up the poster
for what he promises will be this
summer's spookiest comedy here's the one
sheet for possessed
preach no no I mean I have all the
attitude of a guy on a poster where I'm
just like I'm telling a story based on a
poster I would see that movie what does
he sound like the ghostly Pacino oh yeah
Andrea Bacon rights are you going to do
another show at Comic Con this year my
boyfriend I were lucky enough to score
badges yesterday and would love to catch
the show if you guys are gonna do it in
San Diego again this summer um a [ __ ]
yes be when you [ __ ] Andrea bacon it's
called making bacon alright yeah so we
haven't put it on saying I would know
all the details yet but yeah we'll be
doing another showdown at Comic Con so
you're gonna be there come see us this
comes from Warren he says I just
finished watching the 2011 Winnie the
Pooh movie took him that long
I let the credits roll all the way to
the end and suddenly out of the darkness
comes a gigantic furry purple surprise I
saw this film I watched it with my my
baby daughter and I did not watch all
the way to the end I did not see the
post-credits sequence I didn't assume
there would be one in a Winnie the Pooh
movie but during the film if you've seen
it if you have kids and you've seen it
there they talk about this creature
called the Backson throughout the whole
thing especially this is purple mythical
creature and apparently at the end they
showed the Backson and it's voiced by
someone that I was surprised would be in
this film so I brought it in for you to
see here's the little surprise that
comes at the end of the Winnie the Pooh
movie Wow it's amazing but you can find
in the woods a mom and a food and Oh mom
that's a scary-looking fella
gosh maybe these four his things you
know I better pick them up so they won't
get broken that's the last
wow that's amazing
Huell Howser is the voice of the packs
in the window and kerim Taha from
England writes long time listener I have
a request
everyone seems to be enjoying your
Christian Bale furious rant so much I'd
like the McDonald's Frey girl to do the
Christian Bale rant at a colleague what
oh she can get angry too
it's a stressful job working there at
the McDonald's I'm sure oh good for you
do I come and follow you when you'll
make it you'll fry la dee da dee da no
no no you and I are done professionally
there you go there's McDonald's fried
girl along the line of offensive voices
Debra missile rights a long time
listener ever since my cousin hooked me
up with tickets last year when you were
in Phoenix Arizona she's writing from
Phoenix a few weeks ago Ralph did a
horribly stereotypical impression of a
Nazi esque German person a lot of people
were talking about that voice actor we
did it
Deborah write Babylon I believe it was
that's right Berlin Babylon I would love
to hear that horrible horrible voice do
the Green Lantern oath say you're
running segments we have here on the
show now where I pick a voice or you
pick a voice rather and we do the the
votes the the oh that Green Lantern does
when he's recharging his power ring it's
called rouse Green Lantern oath
[Music]
all right here we go the Green Lantern
Note has done by a stereotypical Nazi s
German chavier German pal
sure absolutely yeah in brightest day
yeah by this day our blackest night moon
tonight is black no evil shall escape my
sight when we see you let those who
worship evils might
the Jews we got one right now you are my
power what is that the fuse light [ __ ]
couldn't talk you know Jaime saying what
kind of show did you bring me to every
week we say goodbye to some people in
show business who had wonderful careers
they deserve send ups as they leave this
mortal plane of existence it's a segment
we call the tinsel town stiffs
they will be missed a bad week in the
music industry lost a lot of great
singers and performers this week like
Cleophus staples of the Staple Singers
one of my favorite R&B acts from the 60s
and 70s
she was the soprano with the family who
sang all those great parts and those
songs had a bunch of hits office tax
records back in the 60s and 70s their
biggest one probably is this one she
passed away this week at the age of 78
huge bucket away yeah great great band
and she sang the high parts yes former
temptations singer Damon Harris passed
away this week at the age of 62 he was
not the original falsetto singer of the
attempts he that was Eddie Kendricks who
left left the band in the early 70s he
took over for him it's one of those
great stories he was in a temps cover
band he would sing all the parts at
Eddie Kendricks sang in a tribute band
and when they needed a guy they found
him through the tribute band and they
hired him he got to be a real temptation
he worked for them throughout the 70s
and he was the lead singer on one of
their biggest hits from 1972 papa was a
rolling stone
[Music]
that's here right yeah that was Tony
Sheridan gonna win Tony Sheridan passed
away this week you may not know the name
but he was responsible pretty much for
the Beatles he met the band when they
were in Hamburg Germany working in the
early 60s and he got them a recording
deal to back him up he was an
established singer and the record
company hired the Beatles to back him up
they recorded nine songs together there
the first time the Beatles were ever on
record was a song called my Bonnie
featuring Tony Sheridan the lead vocals
that record went to England kids and
Liverpool started to buy it the guy who
owned the record store said I wonder
what's up with these Beatles everyone
keeps talking about that guy was Brian
Epstein the guy who managed the record
store went to see them became their
manager and that's how the Beatles go so
my Bonnie is like my yeah but it's kind
of a rock and roll version
[Music]
Sanna Tony Sheridan passed away at the
age of 72 this week in Hamburg Germany
stayed there was old life he stayed in
Hamburg Mac shop it was not sure and
what being so angry angry a German one
of my favorite guys that this I didn't
really know who this guy was until this
week but he had a huge role in my
childhood me too his name was w Watts
Biggers and mr. Biggers used to be in
advertising he had to come up with an
idea for a TV show for Saturday mornings
to sell kids cereal in the early 60s he
had no idea what he was going to do he
was it was a slot in the morning line up
that he was competing with it was him
and the competitors were as J Ward and
his partner Scott rocky and bullwinkle
they were supposed to come up with a
show and whoever the show whoever NBC
liked the show better would get the slot
so he was racking his brains with his
partner at the time and they couldn't
come up with anything and his buddy said
you know realize going into the office
we're gonna be the underdog here light
bulb went off and underdog was born of
course one of my favorite cartoons
growing up shoeshine boy remember he
would pop that little pill and he would
get all energy thanks you shine boy
you're humble and lovable this you say
yeah mr. Baker's also wrote the
legendary theme song so I thought in his
honor we'd play the opening to underdog
frog
[Music]
while he makes like
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah they say they won't show the reruns
of that anymore because he takes a pill
pops a pill in order to get his
superpower is true man one generation of
[ __ ] kids to deal with their problems
right going to the parents medicine
chest pull out some valium am underdog
grabbin oxy he gets all [ __ ] up I'm
good up I was dropping a before it was
cool isn't that awesome
what really bums me out man is like when
we were kids they showed us a vision of
the future or their present really where
my burgers had giant robots and take
apart towns that never happened yet no
nobody's ever attacked someplace with a
giant cocoon to June would you imagine I
want to be alive for that then died
right away when the giant robots first
wanna see it going past like they
[ __ ] did it
and that just died before he steps on
you so destroy freaking I always I love
Simon bar sinister the villain from that
thing remember it was my first
impressions I redid it you can do Simon
Barr says Linda Doug I'll get that sweet
honey you ready
when you gonna do Simon person how dare
you sir that was pretty good dude can
you do sweet Polly you know that boys
was based on know that lionel barrymore
oh yeah you gang bill broke good really
you Eve family so if you can if you can
do one you could do the other that's
what I found out later never know I did
Merry Christmas y'all shavings alone do
the whole movie every week we take a
look at a performance from an a-list
actor who gives a less than a list
effort in a film or television show it's
called exquisite acting
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with Ralph Garman
and Kevin small this week's movie is the
cult classic Megaforce if you've never
seen Megaforce from 1982 you know what
you're missing its stars the brilliant
actor Barry Bostwick who I think is a
very talented guy he was a brad in the
Rocky Horror Picture Show he was on Spin
City with Michael J Fox for many many
seasons very talented guy he is in
Megaforce and it was his 1982 the movie
came out directed by hal needham
remember that name yeah this king of
this Hollywood stuntmen he directed
Hooper he directed him all around him
all run and stuff he was big Burt
Reynolds guy but he was a stuntman who
had gone to like a first unit director
and then became a director director in
this film Barry Bostwick has to convince
you that a man can fly on a motorcycle
with a jet coming out the back of it he
fails here's the scene from Megaforce
where Barry Bostwick is flying on his
motorcycle
[Music]
hold it
[Music]
yeah nobody believes that Wow I'd always
heard on Novus true or not but like
originally that's what Trey and Matt
we're gonna that's what Team America was
meant to be they wanted to do a
shot-for-shot remake of America force
really and then the people who have had
Megaforce feel like yeah that's
insulting like [ __ ] you we'll just do
this people who made Megaforce ever seen
Megaforce how insulted could they Jose
those guys would have been so happy like
please take it into the stew the
Megaforce we all dreamed it would be not
that out of that one also every week we
take a look that mistakes happen in
motion pictures and television shows
hundreds of pairs of eyes look at these
things before they reach you the viewer
and no one catches these horrible
horrible mistakes it ends up being [ __ ]
that should not be this this week [ __ ]
that should not be is the legendary film
Animal House you could say what could be
wrong with animals were it could be a
mistake in Animal House that we hadn't
seen well Dan shell from Erie
Pennsylvania wrote in and he found
something it only takes one bad extra to
ruin a scene in a film and if you've
seen a film enough you'll start to watch
the people in the background and you'll
recognize that maybe central casting had
it wrong when they sent over this person
such as the case with Animal House in
this scene where Dean wormer is getting
the key to the city before the big
parade sequence watch the extra and I
will circle him if you will watch the
extra in the upper left-hand corner of
the screen it is well it's [ __ ] that
should not be basically
[Applause]
it gives me great pleasure to present
this ceremonial gold-plated whistle to
this year honorary grand marshal Dean
yeah maybe you don't want to hire the
guy with Tourette's silly as one of your
extras in the scene it can be a little
distracting guys like oh [ __ ] you want
that guy first he was mouthing the
dialogue along with the actor I thought
at first he was having some sort of
grand mal seizure it turns out he's just
a little blinky a few ticks one of my
favorite segments is always the very
creative Hollywood babble-on listeners
who send in photos of Kevin Smith in
places he absolutely doesn't belong it's
a segment called keV in what's keV in
this week well kevin has starred in a
lot of movies you may not have
necessarily known about for instance it
was hard to tell with that mask oh did
you know he was in The Dark Knight
yeah it's only it's only appropriate I
see you got nothing for that I got
nothing for that Kevin also starting on
the classic are movies of all time one
of my favorites Kent that's Kevin Stein
this is my least favorite bit man
like I like the song and [ __ ] but it's
just like stuff there's Kevin and Debbie
Corso wrote in this week and I thought
this was a great idea it says a figure
Kevin which fit right into this role he
loves big flowing clothes here's the
Kevin's next gig
[Laughter]
if I get a vote um I'm Pope cannabis the
first that's who I'm going to that's who
I will be rooting for look it's buddy
Christ over here that they pope fiction
Oh picture in that file on that one that
was Toya Ridge every week we take a look
at the biggest stories and entertainment
news it's the HBO headlines
[Music]
this week it's a bit of an update first
and foremost with ron jeremy pornstar
ron jeremy is continuing his recovery
this week he has been released from the
hospital he's out of the hospital
kind of remarkable after the guy had to
operations for a near-fatal heart
aneurysm just last month he suffered
chest pains got himself to cedars-sinai
and now he is released he is reportedly
recovering in a hollywood hotel you know
that place is filled with like porn star
nurses girls dressed up in the sexy
nurse outfit he says he has lost 45
pounds since going into the hospital in
his dick sadly yes what hospital
cedars-sinai he was at senior prom
[ __ ] gone man if I ever feel like my
arms numb and [ __ ] might get my ass
there they're good yeah they could save
ron jeremy [ __ ] seriously although they
had to remove a a piece of his penis i
think to put it into his heart in order
to say now when he gets excited he's
just puffs out but it'll sure it'll all
work out in long-run one of our favorite
fans here friends here on the show no
han was in the news this week
why don't you come to your senses Oh
Lyndsey Brewer well rumor has it that
she is now calling all of her old
friends drunk these days
desperately what do they call her no no
she is calling them whilst oh she is
desperate according to friends for money
and a job so she has been drunk dialing
all of her old friends like Paris Hilton
Kim Kardashian Nicole Richie and Wilmer
Valderrama
she is Pericles way in them how do we
know this who tells people this is one
of the people she called spilled the
beans really yeah and said that she's
leaving long rambling drunken messages
and people now are avoiding her calls
and not picking up that's kind of sad
yeah like somebody [ __ ] help this
girl man if she called me I totally help
her out
I'd be like come on and sit down we'll
do a podcast together talking cure right
there she's like oh my god what's a
podcast can I snore that get a long
rambling drunk message hi Wilma
this Lyndsey any odd jobs around the
house neato
i rake your leaves got your grass i
smoke your grass lindsay has big
troubles because she borrowed a $1,700
dress in February to attend a charity
gala from one of these high-end fashion
houses called Theia they gave her a
floor-length beaded one-of-a-kind dress
to wear to a charity event they lent it
to her she wore it and then after the
charity event she decided it was time to
hit the nightclubs so she wore this
one-of-a-kind dress into a night club
and sure as [ __ ] the dress ripped while
she was doing whatever she was doing in
that nightclub I'm guessing it ripped in
the knee region I'm just I'm just just I
don't know it's just an assumption
instead of leaving the club or getting
the dress repaired she borrowed a pair
of scissors from the nightclub and cut
off the bottom half of the entire bottom
borrowed gown the best part is when she
returned the dress she didn't even
include the half that she cut off when
she sent it back they were like what the
[ __ ] is this there was they run a
blacklight over it there's all kinds of
stains showing up it's like one of those
NBC news programs where they do the
bedspreads and the motels finding all
kinds of things needless to say they're
very upset and there will be a lawsuit
in her future but nobody lends her
address ever thinking they're gonna get
back get it back today like come on not
great yeah seriously that's a bummer man
and it's a real bummer that she's just
calling people and people are like not
responding and [ __ ] that makes me sad
more than anything else like calling a
Paris Hilton and be like I had a car
that talked to me she calls Herbie does
your does your car talk to you if she
tries to call herself thinking she was
in The Parent Trap with another girl
come on we were in that movie together
help me out come on Lucy so close like
twins
why did everything work out for you we
looked alike also in the news [ __ ] tape
star Kim Kardashian this week
[Music]
looks like Kim's gonna have a girl Kim
and Kanye are gonna have a girl they
announced this week I hope to god she's
ugly
oh I don't I'm not saying that to be
mean I'm saying that because that's the
only that's the only way this girl's
gonna get out alive is if she's hideous
and then it won't put her on the covers
of magazines and they won't put her on a
television show and everything she might
have a shot at a normal life if she's
just a beast yeah what about Kim
Kardashian's sister Chloe I guess I
didn't really work out that it stopped
it and will have no sympathy for Chloe
that's right that's right chewy they're
ready to make the jump to hyperspace Kim
did an interview with d'azur magazine
this week and some fascinating tidbits
in this article one she compares getting
manicures to meditating it's the same
thing for her she goes into a quiet
place and thinks about her life and her
blessings and how she could be a better
person
yes and then she's like and I'll take
the buffing that's right yeah she also
says that she's very happy that on the
family feud recently there was a
question if the United States had a
royal family who would it be and the
Kardashians came in fifth place family
feud is still on the air it is
Kardashians if the United States had a
royal family who would it be
she said the Kardashians came in fifth
place right after the Manson Family
no it was the Kennedys the Obamas the
bushes and the Clintons and then the
Kardashians this is all terrible answer
they're all public servants and then her
and public nuisance and Kardashian says
she credits Kanye West her boyfriend
that he has taught her a lot about
privacy now she refuses to sign
autographs for people she tells them
that my boyfriend won't let me she says
relationship yeah she's about five
minutes away from a Chris Brown I think
why is not signing something some
somehow private you know what I'm saying
like I understand
don't bother me kind of think it you
know it respect my personal space don't
ask me for an autograph so then don't
bother me when you want me to buy I
don't know
your album where your [ __ ] jeans or
anything like you're a Grinch exactly if
you don't have a few times to be like
thanks then well seconds if you're
asking Kim Kardashian for her autograph
you can just go ahead and kill yourself
you're done you're pretty much done on
the on the planet if you run out of
everything else to do and the end of
your bucket list is get Kim Kardashian's
autograph in a world in a world of
autographs Ralf yeah which is worth less
Kim Kardashian's or the person in the
Donald Duck costume laughs I would have
to say Kim is worth less oh yeah because
the person in the dog costume is like
hey I am Donald Duck for all intensive
purposes at that moment he is Kim also
said this week that she understands why
men are sexually obsessed with her
here's her quote if I was a man I would
want to know what it's like to have sex
with myself
Jesus I respect everyone's right to
[ __ ] make a living and [ __ ] and I'm
glad shit's working out for a [ __ ]
family but like stop [ __ ] talking the
ironic part is most men in Los Angeles
do know what it's like to have sex with
her so that happened why we're talking
about the hideous Chloe she is not only
a wookie she is also unemployed she's
angry about it - this is unemployed yeah
the New York Post reports that she's
been fired as co-host of The X Factor
oh no wookie no touchy she was
co-hosting with Mario Lopez and Mario
Lopez just
outshined court khloe kardashian to
shows you how shitty a host khloe
kardashian was she's now the Brian
Dunkleman of The X Factor basically
producers realize having Khloe
Kardashian on a talent show was like
having Kim Kardashian teach a physics
class so it all worked out honey boo boo
while we're talking about reality shows
mama June of honey boo boo said she
refuses that her daughter's become like
the Kardashians oh my god
even that woman it's like that girl is
horrible
when these inbred hillbillies are saying
bad families [ __ ] up these are people
who eat cheese balls off the ground
where their chicken shits in their house
and they're saying no we don't want to
be like that family no we're here eating
sketti with our pig but the one family
we don't want to be like are those
[ __ ] Kardashians
mama June said my girls are not high
maintenance like them girls Oh aren't
hillbillies cute they prefer to play in
the mud than shop for new clothes says
June she's talking about her children
yes Pig no her children Joseph says they
want one people be to Los Angeles any
time becoming like them Beverly
Hillbillies she said anybody explained
that was a television show they thought
it was a documentary she's like we also
ain't gonna have no wars and the stars
I think Jeff Rose kinfolk she said he
was a cousin or something more people
who don't deserve what they have Prince
Michael Jackson the 16 year old son of
Michael Jackson was named as Prince
Michael J's name is Prince Michael
Jackson so we're just when we were kids
it was like who do you like better
Prince of Michael Jackson and this kid
is like I am Prince Michael jacket all
Prince Michael Jackson 16 year old son
of Michael has been hired by
Entertainment Tonight as a correspondent
for their program well he's earned it
when you think about the years of
Journalism school that he went to Oh
like you need journalism school for
[ __ ] entertainment tonight may be
able to ask a question though all right
you have to be able to put a sentence
together
okay like what like [ __ ] - so Kim
Kardashian what do you think it's like
what do you think men think about having
sex with you you know what I'm saying it
doesn't take that I'd like to have sex
okay
his first interview is with James Franco
zach braff and sam raimi for their film
oz the great and powerful and apparently
during the interview his microphone cut
out so they had to replace his mic pack
and everybody on the program for the
entire evening was saying look at how
cool and collected he was while we
swapped out his microphone so the bar
has been lowered yes
he's light he's like the special
liveries kid who finishes the race oh
look he didn't fall and he got here
let's give him a round of applause it's
not so much success as it is not failure
here's the clip from the show I [ __ ] you
not where the corner of the coho so I
don't know who this bimbos name is but
she's like hey you were amazing because
that we had to change the mic packin you
didn't [ __ ] your magic Huell Howser
you're amazing your battery died and we
had to change it and you didn't throw up
he is praising Prince Michael Jackson
for his amazing composure after you Oh
for [ __ ] sake
I don't know is this the kid that they
used to have the blanket over him when
you know that was blanket that was
Michael's other kid blanket right no
Prince Michael was one of these to put
Halloween masks on all the time when he
would carry him around outside so when
he says I grew up in this business what
he means is I grew up behind a Halloween
mask being shuttled from limo to limo
without ever having actually done
anything and that's pretty much the same
thing as being on entertainment right
we're being a Kardashian for that matter
Prince Michael says he would like to
become a producer director screenwriter
and actor no he wants to be Ben Affleck
when he grows up
oh he forgot astronaut in fireman man
speaking of the Jackson kids no this is
not a lot you know uh Jermaine yeah he
made personally but I know his eldest
your majesty that's kind of sweet
oh stop I mean you couldn't do that in
the Catholic Church when we were kids
but you could only pick like your first
name or your middle name had to be the
name of the state a saint so I don't
know any Saint your Majesties or
anything like that no no it the Catholic
Church you had to have your middle name
at least had to be a saint right that's
a confirmation name and they will also
accept touch me I think it's an as an
employer there's a name that you could
also have in the Catholic Church that's
why I'm Ralph touch me Garmin that's it
let do a lot of problems as an altar boy
but I won't get into that
Shia LaBeouf was supposed to be on
Broadway he was supposed to debut in a
Broadway show called orphans and he has
quit he quit this week apparently he had
a big blowout with his co-star Alec
Baldwin they had a big fight and Shia
LaBeouf walked off the project and he
will no longer be starring on Broadway
in that play maybe he got a call from
his [ __ ] car buddy
I don't know Shia LaBeouf but just based
on nothing he seems like a dick I don't
know but doesn't he seem like a dick he
seems like he's kind of working some
[ __ ] out right he's he's grown up in
front of everybody
it's a very nice way of saying he's a
dick now Alec Baldwin don't know the man
personally seems like a massive dick so
whose side are you taking in arguing
Shia LaBeouf and Alec Baldwin you don't
you just sit there and eat popcorn the
director he started posting emails that
he had shared with the cast and the
director and stuff back and forth on his
Twitter account once this story broke
one of the emails was the director
saying you two are incompatible
so confirming the fact that it was
between those guys but Alec Baldwin
meanwhile had another problem when he
had a photographer and reporter accost
him Costin they approached him outside
his apartment in New York this week Alec
grabbed the reporter female reported by
the
Herman told her reportedly I want to
choke you to death he said there's a
woman it was a woman yeah she was asking
him about the lawsuit that was filed
against his wife Gloria who's a yoga
instructor
she's being sued because a former
student claimed that overcrowding in her
class caused him to suffer serious
injury he can no longer blow himself can
you do that no but if I was gonna be a
techie yoga class that would be my end
result that's what I'd be shooting we're
just like I'll stay if you can get me
from here to there that's right how
flexible can you get me I want to choke
you to death is what he said reportedly
and he allegedly used a racial slur to
her photographer sidekick who happened
to be an african-american retired New
York police detective [ __ ] outta here
yeah he didn't use the n-word though
wasn't that bad
so then what how do I say this without
offending anyone [ __ ] he didn't [ __ ]
say that yeah he said [ __ ] City really I
said it [ __ ] but is that that's what
they said he said that's what they said
he said come on that's almost like
[ __ ] worse man that's like so so like
ancient 1940 southern it's gonna say did
he step out of a time machine like a
plantation owner well I guess we have
our answer who's the bigger dick between
Shia LaBeouf's and Alec Baldwin yeah
Justin Bieber that's the answer Justin
Bieber the bigger dick he's still
feuding with Patrick Carney drummer for
the Black Keys you know they had that
Twitter feud going back and forth we've
talked about a little bit we did Carney
said that Bieber is rich so he shouldn't
mind not being nominated for a Grammy
this year
Bieber then tweeted the Black Keys
drummer should be slapped around what
that the result of that was he mobilized
the Bieber nation all the believers all
the believers and they started
bombarding this poor guy Patrick Carney
with all these hateful tweets like and I
quote you are a closeted gay man
which is a hell of a thing coming from a
Justin Bieber fan
just died died and you need to be
punched in the face with a brick I never
thought of that before ma'am
so now Kearney is responding by he's
changed his profile on Twitter to have a
picture of Justin Bieber as his avatar
and he is responding as Bieber to all
the people who hate him with tweets like
this one to all my peoples you make my
life so full of swag i swag out all day
just thinking about all the swag you
guys inspire me to swag with
so I think he got the last laugh maybe
Bieber's pissed off cuz people still
talking about that guy who tried to
murder and castrate him I remember that
story man in December we talked about
this criminal who was serving a life
sentence in Vermont but he hired two
guys outside of the prison to murder and
castrate Justin Bieber and his bodyguard
that was the big plan they had cops
found these guys and they intervened
before they were able to act out and
finish this plan but now we have audio
tapes of the guy talking on the prison
phone to his conspirators telling them
about the plan to murder and castrate
Justin Bieber which by the way they're
gonna castrate somebody don't you that
before you murder them I think use it
all backwards there here is him talking
to one of the hit men this is the audio
about how they plan to strangle and then
castrate him and how they would do it we
go over the people son with you no no I
like the way I work dude the way I work
is I like to know as little as possible
he's gonna use one of the things you
gave him to get him out of this and then
he's gonna go take care of it we went we
bought some you know the hedge clippers
yeah they got hedge clippers that's what
they were gonna use to castrate man I'm
with you sir
but it was a dude who was in prison who
had no connection to him whatsoever
right now he was a fan but but no
connection to him wasn't like I used to
work for Bieber nice no no no ver now
he's just a big fan well apparently not
that big a fan he had Bieber tattoos
which in prison make you very popular
I'm sure you've got baby baby baby oh
over your sphincter the Oh being the
sphincter yeah
swag however they didn't say how they
were going to immobilize him that's what
I was thinking what would they use to
immobilize Justin Bieber and I was so
glad someone sent me this picture this
week this is a real thing Justin Bieber
duct tape this is a real product that
you can buy if you're putting your name
on duct tape you are asking to get
apprehended and immobilized in my
opinion Justin Bieber hedge clippers
that's what I was wondering to finish
off the jeggi imagine you get captured
and they're [ __ ] putting tape over
your mouth and you're like oh the irony
yes my officially endorsed tape I hope
it's cheap and I could bite through it
this is another story were talking about
the Bob Guccione the guy rent penthouse
he died and left a lot of his belongings
behind in a storage facility and the guy
bought it at an auction I found all this
stuff inside there unpublished nude
photos of Madonna all kinds of
correspondence with Guccione and the
Unabomber and other people and one of
the most talked about pictures was only
described as a young Arnold
Schwarzenegger performing a sex act and
everyone was very curious as to what
that could be and why they would phrase
it in such a way well we got a hold of
the picture this week and this hasn't
hasn't been officially confirmed as the
photo but everyone seems to think it is
so and this isn't a Photoshop thing this
is the real photo of Schwarzenegger he
is very young in it with a group of
people and we'll see exactly what sex
act they were talking about here's the
photo
here's Arnold right there these are the
well disguised people he's with and can
we zoom in on this region to see what
the sex act might be yeah it's it's it's
Arnold holding a woman and digitally
molesting her with his finger while she
sits on his lap that's not a sex act
that's harassment not if she's his
housekeeper it's just business as usual
for Arnold more offensive pictures Paris
Hilton was in the news this week for a
change we haven't seen her in a while
she was out on the slopes with her
boyfriend River that's his name he fell
he had a bad cut on his leg he was
bleeding so badly they had to call the
Ski Patrol so they showed up and I
started tending to her boyfriend and so
Paris did what any concerned girlfriend
would do she started posing for photos
in front of him as he lay in the snow
and then posting them on her own website
no she posted such a scary day on the
slopes after seeing the gash on rivers
leg I almost passed out I've never seen
a cut that deep in my life he is so
brave I can't even imagine the pain he
went through today it was accompanied
with this photograph here she is making
sure you get her good side
here's River on this side I'm okay
buddy's concerned yeah someone needs to
remind River that the river runs one way
away from [ __ ] her man
yikes every once in a while we take a
look at forthcoming movies that are
promised to suck and there gonna be a
theater near you so beware their movies
that will suck
Michael Bay but make movies gonna make
my movies that will suck this week's
movie that will suck it's the return of
Roger Rabbit but not the sequel we've
been hoping for for all these many years
why could this suck because they've
announced that Roger Rabbit and Mickey
Mouse are going to be teaming up in a
remake of a Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis
movie called the stooge stop it indeed
madam stop it indeed it's been confirmed
by the guy who created Roger Rabbit Gary
K wolf the guy wrote the original book
said yeah it's being pitched to Disney
Pixar as a 100% animated film it will
team up Mickey Mouse and Roger Rabbit
ensuring a merchandising bonanza and
it's gonna be too dear
no word on whether it's gonna be 2d or
3d but it looks like it's going to be
CGI
so two of them doing a remake even
animated characters now we're doing
reboots and remakes of movies we're
gonna do a Dean Martin Jerry Lewis movie
called the stooge but if you were gonna
do something that was guaranteed why
would you remake the stooge I know a
movie that no one knows or cares if I'm
these cats I'm like okay man let's put
[ __ ] Roger Rabbit and Mickey Mouse in
Avatar there you go because that made a
lot of money or the Godfather and moving
is of course tomorrow night's the big
night Oscar night Hollywood's biggest
Hollywood's biggest night that's right
sadly won't be as fun for me because
they had rumoured that the James Bond
actors were going to appear together on
stage for the first time ever every
actor would ever play James Bond on this
week producers announced that that rumor
has been squashed it's not going to
happen
producers said it's something else
something very unique something very
exciting but no we're not getting all
the bonds together Adele will still be
singing Skyfall her hit from the most
recent James Bond movie rumor has it now
there's
Sean Connery walk out in stage and slap
Adele that's what's gonna happen I would
look forward to that Kevin and I are big
geeks every week we take care I'd like
to take a look at the geek news
[Music]
this week's geek News starts off with
Star Trek Star Trek fans tens of
thousands of them have gone to Pluto
rocks calm trying to get one of Pluto's
newly discovered moons named after
Spock's home planet Vulcan
oh that's cool apparently they are
taking names now by popular vote that's
who the how they decided what they were
gonna call Pluto's new moons currently
called p4 and p5 oh you sunk my
battleship he said Vulcan is one of the
choices and apparently Star Trek fans
have turned out by tens of thousands to
vote for that at Pluto rocks calm voting
ends on Monday by the way so right up to
get Kim Kardashian's autograph if you
vote for a moon of Pluto thing well
shatter and Leonard Nimoy have gone to
Twitter to beg people to vote for Vulcan
so there could be an actual Vulcan Red
Alert
yes
[ __ ] plate is one of them no it doesn't
say what the other choices are but I
don't think I need them are nearly as
interesting as Vulcan Vulcan I guess
would be I mean what else is there in
pop culture like Tatooine I guess you
could go that route if you were Star
Wars fan yeah speaking of Star Wars Mark
Hamill ego the Living Planet from Marvel
they could call it ego
there you go the Living Planet yeah I'm
sorry go to Mark Hamill what was they
Green Lantern was the planet the living
plan be cola oh the planet logo oh yeah
hey man aren't you doing a voice you
doing a cartoon voice recently yeah I
just did a cartoon voice for the
upcoming Avengers Assemble animated
series
my first my first first super-villain
yeah my first superval my first foray
out of sort of FAMILY GUY getting into
animation stuff you always asked me how
do you get an animation voiceovers I was
like [ __ ] if you find out tell me I
don't know they call it the people
family guy very nice they call me and
that me do but I really don't work that
much so for someone else to hire me was
very exciting so they hired you I play a
character called mojo which if you know
the x-men at all you know mojo is the
guy used to set up these battle Royals
and and broadcast them throughout the
galaxy big globby looking guy yeah
the black chair much like this one oq
Mark Hamill was on Entertainment Tonight
this week yeah too bad he wasn't
interviewed by Prince Michael Jackson
saying that he's indeed talking to the
producers of the upcoming Star Wars film
to reprise his role as Luke Skywalker's
has talked to him and to Carrie Fisher
and we know that already that Harrison
Ford has been approached so they may all
reprise their roles in the upcoming film
which would probably be the next
generation of Jedi whatever to follow
them but they would have at least some
role in the film [ __ ] fantastic
I can't wait that's awesome yes really
good news Lucas said what the [ __ ] are
they saying Michael Bay was in the news
this week a lot of people are very upset
about his move for the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle film as if they weren't
already because he's making them from
space well there's a rumor he was gonna
have them come from outer space which is
a problem for a lot of the fans but even
more so was the news that he hired Megan
Fox to play April O'Neill on the trip
I told you I told you people are upset I
thought he was like she's a [ __ ] she
said she said some [ __ ] about him on
transformers or the last transformers
they did together she did an interview
where she said he's like Napoleon he
wants to create this insane infamous
madman reputation he wants to be like
Hitler on his sets and he is he's a
nightmare to work for and she's going
back to work for him yes so he fired her
from the third Transformers movie but
he's now hired her to be in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles right on so the
lesson here is shut the [ __ ] up and I'll
put you in another movie and I guess she
learned it I guess she did bummer
um since we're talking about Megan Fox
this this email came this week my head
exploded this is not a photoshopped
photo by the way this is with all the
talk about Megan Fox I thought I'd send
you this sweet photo of Megan Fox and
the desperate teenage admirer which begs
the question has young Kevin Smith found
a time machine have you ever seen this
photo before or the guy approaching her
with the rose holy [ __ ] that does look
like [ __ ] look like you as a kid it
really does man you're a looper I assure
you if I was looping back through time
it wouldn't be to come see her come back
and fix her thumb she's got a club thumb
what she's got a toe thumb yes yeah
she's got a club thumb it's like half of
thumb with like a nail bigger than your
face on it well you can't see if she
hides it all the time though right yeah
it's our only way there one flaw man
yeah man it's like what is the
[ __ ] they dipped in the water
and he was perfect set for the Haley's
yeah Chili's man that's our Achilles
zombie huh I didn't know that make for
some reason that makes her more
interesting that's what I always said
like I felt before I got [ __ ] her she's
all pretty and [ __ ] now I'm like oh
she's a mutant what is her superpower
rau fire comes out of her eyes no she's
gonna [ __ ] up thumb that's all that's
it yeah it would be Thumbelina
very guys well as you know for many many
months now Kevin and I have been
obsessed with the legendary stories of
the size of Liam Neeson's [ __ ] we can't
help ourselves and people keep going to
Neeson [ __ ] calm and they keep adding
larger and larger stories to the legend
so every week we have to ask the musical
question just how big is Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] this week's top facts about Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] as always you can go to
nice and calm if you'd like to add your
own or read them all Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big he's letting Lindsay Lohan
crash in his urethra I think that is
sweet is very kind she's burnt scandals
though that's the only problem is marry
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
he's already named Pluto's new moons he
calls them my kidney stones Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is no big Kanye West won't
allow it to sign autographs anymore but
it does anyway big dick yeah Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when people walk
the length of it Ryan Seacrest stops
them and asks them who they're wearing
him it's its [ __ ] is so big I'm sorry
this one made me laugh so hard
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Christopher
Reeves horse fell off of it it became a
quadriplegic
oh that is not Superman oh come on it's
okay it's not - tsunami it's plenty
tsunami
leonie's the [ __ ] is so big that when it
does the Harlem shake it actually shakes
Harlem Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
[Applause]
Spike Lee has given it it's his
permission to use the n-word on film
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he has
an orgasm and his sperm reach the
surface they get the bends and lastly
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's kept
on its own wildlife reserve called Liam
country safari and I think we have a
photo of one of the kids driving through
there running into him ladies and
gentlemen of Hollywood man if you had a
good time this evening thank you so much
for coming out tonight we really do
appreciate it it was a rocky show but we
brought her in for a landing here all a
big part of a man thanks for being here
thanks for selling us out this week on
Friday the trailer for Jay and Silent
Bob's super groovy cartoon movie on the
Internet and the tickets go on sale so
look for that on Friday tomorrow I'm
doing a three-hour Oscar special with my
wife and we'll put that out on SModcast
so you can hear that after you watch the
Oscars you go back and relive the magic
yes right now they're a bit early go I
can't believe that [ __ ] dick won an
award he used to put his balls on my
neck Aflac
at black so that being said keep your
ear out for that this week and and I
think that'll do it for us man that is
Hollywood babble-on for this week I'm
Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman ladies and gentlemen
give it up for Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman Hollywood babble-on
live at the lemons
[Music]